hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar high
tider adeno associated virus production
that is cost effective and scalable
i am michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots
and brought to you by gibko by thermo
fisher scientific
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker chao
yen lu
senior manager cell biology at thermo
fisher scientific
chao yen you may now begin your
presentation
thank you michelle very much for your
kind of introduction
i'm very glad to have this opportunity
today to
introduce our newly developed high title
adeno associated virus
production system that is cost effective
and scalable
and the thermofisher our mission is to
enable our customers
to make the world healthier cleaner and
safer we are the scientists and our
purpose
is to enable our customers to fulfill
their scientific purpose
that means to us the success of our
customers
is our success and we take the pride
in our mission
thermostation scientific does offer the
end-to-end
solutions that span the entire viral
vector workflow
include the upstream process and the
downstream process
we do offer superior products services
and expertise to help our customers
to develop breakthrough fail and gene
therapies
today i'm going to focus on part of the
upstream process
which highlighted here in red includes
cell culture plasmid transfection and
viral vector
production
the gitfuel brand av max
the helper-free av production system
is a scalable high title with a
simplified av
production workflow we could say is the
cost
effective you know based on the high
title
so this entire system includes the viral
production cell line
2.0 and the viral production media
av max transfection kit this kit
includes a transfection reagent
transaction booster
and the enhancer the system also
includes a viral flex complexion buffer
and the lysis buffer this whole system
as the prototype of product already
available
in the middle of february of this year
the whole ruo system
will be launched in august this year
and with all validated per uh
performances
the gimpril brand the cell therapy
system the cts
av max the whole system will be launched
in next year
2022
why we call this system is a helper free
so we use the triple transfection
technology to call transfected the three
plasma dna
and optimize the ratio to the 293
base the producing cell line to produce
av
virus particles and the mature av
cascade proteins will be
produced
in next several slides i will address
each component in this whole system
in this system as i mentioned earlier we
have this
newly developed clonal 293 f derived
cells along with amino original free
chemically defined protein-free cell
free
viral production media this media is not
only support the vpc 2.0
banking recover culture expansion
as well as support the transfection and
the production
so the new avmax transfection religion
kit
includes the three components all
chemical
defined amino original free they work
together
so the in addition the complexation
buffer this
first time we have the chemical defined
and
amino original free in addition all
these components
we also included polysorbate 20 base the
license buffer in
our system just to provide the easy and
convenient
for downstream sample extraction
in this slide i summarized some
attributes
of this new development of viral
production cell line 2.0
this is a cloning cell line derived from
hex293s cells with the proof
of coloniality and the clear lineage
documentation
this cells if you compare with the
typical 293p
cells in absence of the lv
sv 40 large t-axis really reduce
the regulatory concerns this new clonal
cell line
can grow in the viral production cell of
viral production media
and high density in suspension the
typical peak cell density
around 12 to 40 million per ml in the
shake flask
and based on the initial saving density
this colonial cell lines also produce
the much
higher the viral tighter compared to
their parental cells
the doubling time of these cells is
relatively
similar to the parental cells just
slightly or grow faster
and a little bit shorter the doubling
time averagely you know
below 24 hours so the good feature of
the cells
is non-clunky the phenotype and give you
the robustness you know the scalability
and the grid of passage stability
typically we require a passage of 30 and
we test it beyond that the documented
ctmp bank cell line will be available
together with our cts the whole system
in next
year 2022 in this slice on the right
panel
you could see six images
these are the images we took during
during the single cell cloning process
on the top panel from the left to right
you can see
the image before sitting with clear
background that's the image we took
before we see the cells but after we
entered the media
on the day zero we exceeded the cells
and 0.3 to 0.5
per cell per bell and we catch the
single cells
and the day after just like 24 hours
posted
the single cell cloning we catch the two
cells the cells doubled
and the one continued to take the image
on the different
day until the single cell
expanded big enough the colony and ready
to be transferred
from 96 well played to the 24 vale plate
and the further down to the chick flux
and default the screening
here i show some feature with this viral
production
cells 2.0 on the left on the top
i show the cells in the quick recovery
post the thought this is three different
cell bank bank one two and
three we saw on the same time and we
monitor the viability and the vcd
right post the thought post result
viability is really high along the 97
98 percent the one thing i want to point
out
is the day one post of the thought the
parental transfer f cells
usually show the viability job between
five to ten percent
but this colonial cell line didn't show
any
viability job opposed to the thought
this allowed our customer
use their cells as quickly as possible
they could
start their production long in early as
passage three
once they recovered the cells expanded
to the
certain level they can do the production
immediately the bottom on the left
is average doubling time i calculated
this based on the routine cell culture
three day or four cell culture and early
log phase
and you could say cross the passage
eight to passage 48
the cells keep the similar doubling time
how about the stability of this cell
line we monitored
not only the cell growth we also tested
the viral production
and the different passage of these cells
in the middle panel on the top
you could say the gross curve analysis
with
different passages of cells from passage
12 up to passage
29 they show almost identical
the girl's pattern on the bottom
we show the normal routine maintain the
cells
when you come to the cells on the by
cell or cdx
you take the image you could see the
cells really
distributed evenly and the single cells
is really not
clumpy there's a much better feature
compared
to an x3t and on the right of the
picture
is the five million cells viability
around 99
and you see the evenly non-column piece
feature
on the right panel we tested all five
serial types for the passive stability
based on the viral production here i
show you two
two stereotypes as a representative as
you can see
the cells can produce uh the viral
viral vector and the early and passage
three as
late as passive 33 you do not really see
the difference
between the early passage cells and the
later passage cell
they gave almost the same level of the
performance the second
important component in the system is
viral production media
this media is designed to support the
vpc 2.0
this media is the aof chemical defined
in the manufacturer and the ctmp in our
difficult facility
supports the vpc grow up to 12
14 million per ml but this media does
require
the supplement supplementation with four
millimolar growth max
the atp powder format of this media will
be available together with the whole cts
system in next year 2020.
in this slide on the right i show you
the gross
curve with the vpc cells and the
different
scale in this viral production media
range from 125 ml strip flask
to 2 liter lately we also tested in five
liter
and bioreactor because we drawn in
different time in different
assets so i didn't incorporate that data
in the same figure
but they do show the similar growth
pattern
how about our transfection regions is it
suitable for the larger scale
so here i show you some attributes of
this
new transaction reagents it is a lipid
space
the transfection region and needs to
work together with the booster
to achieve the high transfection
efficiency and
produce the high viral tighter we
simplified
the transfection protocol made it
adaptable
and suitable to the large scale
transfection
in the middle panel i show you pre-mixed
av
max transfection reagent and booster how
stable these pre-mixed
regions you can see less than one
minutes
up to two days and lately i tested even
two months they are stable and the four
degree
so you do not really need to worry about
this step
as a on the right panel the light blue
bar
represents the complex holding type
once you dilute to your dna you pre-mix
your transaction region the booster
you enter the mix to dilute the dna how
stable they are
so we tested more than five different
stereotypes
some stereotypes is stable up to 40
minutes
but majority stereotypes show the best
the time being
is between 20 to 30 minutes
uh here i want to point out if you use
your plasma dna specially optimized
either too big or too small you might
want to consider
to test the optimal complexation timing
how about the av max enhancer how much
the tighter decrease
they could increase in the in this whole
system
this enhancer is chemically defined aos
enhance the production of av particles
in the vpc 2.0 cells the addition of
this enhancer
is flexible here we show you can end
the time of cell preparation for
transfection
just give you a simplified the workflow
you do not need
to come back and after transfection to
do
addition but if you forgot you still can
do
and it's quite flexible wheezing for
hours
five hours is all can be done so the
effective enhancer on av tighter
showed in the middle panel as you can
see in the presence of enhancer
the av tighter almost double more than
double
and the way further down to test the
function title
the transducer you need based on per mil
and you can see
also the function title also doubled in
the presence of
the av max enhancer
lastly i want to talk about the lysis
buffer the lysis buffer is polysorbate
it's a 20 we usually call and the base
the buffer
and it's very easy to use we made the
10x concentrated
basically you just based on the volume
and the 10 percent
to your express transfected culture
crew culture and the continue incubator
under 37 degrees
for additional two or three hours after
72 hours i mean
on the day of harvest then you
centrifuge
and collect the supernatant as your
lysate
and move down to the downstream
purification or downstream
just like quantification process
in next several slides i will show you
the
overall system performance and well as
the comparison study with some
competitors
transfection regions or competitors
culture media
here i briefly introduced the av max
transfection protocol here list and the
chic flux scale
but it is very easy to adapt to the
large scale
such as the bioreactor
on the day before transfection usually
for the customer they use 293t cells
they need the subculture the cells
and the before transaction because of
the robustness of this cell line
and the high performance of this viral
production media
we could avoid that step so you just
maintain yourself as a routine culture
such as 0.6 for three days then
on the day of transaction you just
dilute with additional fresh media
dilute the cells to three milli or you
can culture 1.2 for two days
then you dilute to 3 milli typically 1.
1.2 0.6 for 2 or 3 days culture the
cells
range about 4.5 to 5 milli so you dilute
it to 3 milli
even more we optimize this protocol
suitable for large scale you could
culture
1.5 million per meal just for one day
and next day the cells double
because i mentioned doubling time just
about 24 hours a little bit less
so next day from 1.5 million they could
reach about
3 million range from 2.9 to 3.1 or 3.2
all depends
you do the transaction in the morning or
afternoon
this way allow you to avoid to change
the parameter
if we run the bioreactor keep the same
volume for cell culture
and for transfection on the day of the
transfection
the day zero the step two you can end
the one percent the av max enhancer
to the three milli uh diluted cell
culture
then you could start to prepare the dna
and transfection region complex
as everybody knows the diluted dna
in complexity buffer is quite stable
typically we recommend to use 10 percent
of the complexation volume relatively to
your
transfection volume then in the step 4
you premix the transfection regions and
the booster
as i talked before because this mix is
quite stable
you can mix the time between 1 minutes
to 10 minutes
then you'll add the pre-mixed the
regions and booster
to your diluted dna here i want to point
out one thing accepted the media you
would like to pre-warm
before you dilute the cells all other
reagents you could just grab
from the refrigerator and directly to
use
no preform required but the complexation
reaction takes place
in the room temperature in the hood for
20 to 25
minutes then you add the complex to the
culture
in about three days typically 70 hours
plus minus 4 hours you could perform the
cell lysis
or measure the av tighter or just like
directly move downstream
the purification
how about the system performance we
did applied the system approach
try to integrate of all the components
to achieve the higher optimal
performance
here i show you five stereotypes or we
used during the development work
typically the the title ranging from one
time
11 or 1.5 times 11.
so we use the gfp as gene of interested
during our development based on the beta
tester of our tester
feedback they use their optimized the
plus and dna constructs
they could get much higher the vg per
meal
some got three to five time eleven some
guys are seven to eight times
eleven and even one customer show over
uh time to time twelve so
uh this really is uh uh the plus and dna
based
i want to point out the viability and
the vcd and harvest
the viability on the harvest typically
range from 70 percent
to 80 based on the stereotypes
if the transfection is not efficient
all your constructs didn't work well
maybe
the viability could see could be
arranged about 90.
that means that the cells didn't produce
enough you know the viral particles
that's an indicator so the vcd and the
harvest
ranging from 4.5 million to 5.5 million
per ml because we transfected on three
million
the cells is barely double uh
less than double
how about the scalability we call this
the scalable system
and here i show you some data we tested
in the 24 well place that's a little bit
down scale
and the tested in the bioreactor and
almost
every size of sheet flask on the left
panel you can see the 24 deep well place
the volume is ranging 2.5 to 3 mils
per valve and compared to the chic flask
125 mils the capacity with
initial transfection volume of 30 ml you
can see
the vg per meal is is really compatible
in the shake flask we tested 125 ml
street flask
up to five liter sheet flasks in five
liter sheet flux
the initial volume is 2 liter
so with addition the 200 mils complexion
buffer
is about 2.2 by end of unwrap
so you can see across different size of
the sheet flask
we got a comparable the vg premiere the
tighter
further down we check the infectivity of
the function tighter
in all these scales in addition to the
multiple wheel plate and the sheet flask
we further tested the system
in the bioreactor it's a high performer
financed by reactor the capacity is
three liter
the final production volume is two liter
we compare with the typical 125 chic
flasks
so not only the title is comparable we
also monitored
the postal transfection growth profile
and the bio profile such as
the ammonia glucose lactate
and the ph and we see in the bioreactor
because well control the system
even more robust and more repeatable how
about
repeatability and reproducibility of the
av max the whole system
if you just check the vcd viability from
wrong to wrong it's very very consistent
but when you run the qpcr you do say
sometimes
between the time to time wrong to wrong
and the operator to operator you see
the variation something like 20 30
percent
probably everybody believes the qp
sciences sometimes produce the
variation and not just like ourselves
media and transfection reads this
performance
so that's why we try to further optimize
and our qpsr essay to reduce the
variation
based on solely based on the assay
as you can see we tested three different
stereotypes
multiple time and different operators
and basically
this system we could conclude is
repeatable
and reproducible
how to compare this a whole system to
other transfection regions
other media are in the market so pi pro
and the pr backs
are two widely re used the uh
transfection regions
in the viral vector production industry
so in the left panel you could say
we use the same cells vpc 2.0
same viral production media we just
replaced
the av max transfection region kit with
the pi pro pmx
effect pearl and you can see
significantly the tighter decrease
when you swap the transaction region
heat
so we would like to stress is to use
the whole system because we optimized
each component to achieve the optimal
performance on the right panel you can
see
the two popular cultural media one
is getting called freestyle 17 one is
the
urban balance cd hack293 media
in combination with pi pro and you can
see
we would show more than four five six
false increase and in tighter if you use
the complete av max the system
finally i would like to
show some data about downstream
purification
this purification for the av6 was
done with the thermo facial gold pure
avx
purification resin it's all our thermo
facial
reagents as you can see here is a
relatively not very large scale
is a one liter chic flax production
around the 250 to 300 ml
production loaded you know 200 mils
as you can see is the shark illusion
peak and with these five males
and we calculate the recovered the av6
particles relatively is about the 70
percent
the purified av6
if we want to purify the av-6 efp on the
sds page
you could see the the vp you know the
viral
the the the testate protein vp1 vp2 vp3
indicated in the illusion fraction we
collaborated with
our uh collaborator and the ucsd
uh they did the transmission electronic
microscope
and show the image on the right and the
calculated the empty fold ratio
of this purified av6 the full ratio
is about the 30 32 percent the empathy
is about
68 right now we really focus on
the large-scale production use this
system and the downstream purification
with
other stereotypes and i think that's all
i have for today
i'm really happy to answer any questions
you might have
thank you
well thank you chao yen for your
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
so your first question
is how do tigers compare
to using pe pei based systems
oh this is a really typical question
because
so many customers currently use the pei
and as i show you the data in the slides
you know what is the transaction region
compares comparison
one is the pi in combination with
competitive
the media so the tighter is about four
to six volts increase
with our whole av max system
hey great thank you your next question
is
how do the vpc 2.0 cells differ
from the lv max vpc cells
okay lv max vpc cells
is viral production cell line the first
generation
that cells is not clonal cell line it's
just like
the pool 293 f cells adapted into the lv
max media
the vpc 2.0 the sixth generation
the viral production you know the cell
line 2.0
is clonal two-colon cell lines
and screening based on the av production
is the clonus sally and the high tighter
cell line
thank you now how much drop in titers do
you see
if no enhancer is used
as i show you the data in the slides
with the addition of the av max
enhancer you could double the titles
almost in all the serial types we tested
okay great thank you now your next
question when
will the gmp version of aav max be
available
uh i as i'm aware
should be the second quarter next year
2022.
great now are there differences between
the
ruo and cts versions of the product
oh yes the components in the system
in the io or cts should be the same
the cts version when launched will be
manufactured and the cdmp and carries
the benefits of the cts brand
means includes the additional testing
with all the regulatory support
thank you chaoyan your next question are
the residual assays available
for the components for the ruo
i would say right now is not available
but the residue
assets for the transfection regions and
the enhancer
will be available when the cts version
the whole system
launched in next uh second quarter of
next year
great thank you we have one last
question here
are all the components animal origin
free
yes as i emphasized the several times
during my presentation all the
components
in the av max system are amino original
free
and chemically defined
thank you chavian now do you have any
final comments for
our audience before we go today i would
like to
say thank you to all the audience who
take the time
and pay attention uh to
to know more about our this new system
and i would like to say one more time
again
this system is really produce a high
titer and
we'll consider is really the cost
effective system
and the iuos you know the whole system
will be available shortly
in the august of this year thank you
thank you very much
thank you chanyeon for your time today
and we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor gibko by thermo
fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i would like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
now this webcast can be viewed on demand
and lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event
until next time goodbye